[Music]
hey guys what's up we have just recently
done a video about the ancestors and the
family tree of Cthulhu the great old one
the sleep of relay and the great dreamer
he is undoubtedly one of the first
fictional monsters of gigantic
proportions created by HP Lovecraft in
1928 the name Cthulhu is probably
derived from the worth photonic derived
from the classical Greek meaning
subterranean as apparently suggested by
Lovecraft himself had the end of the
1923 jail the rats in the wall so I was
thinking that what if we pitched Cthulhu
in the monster verse would he fit in
with the other Titans or just sleep to
be awakened by an alpha call what if he
battles the other Titans and asserts his
dominance only to face off against
Godzilla we shall discuss all these in
this video but before you continue on
please subscribe to our Channel Ave for
we have lots and tons of videos on
masters kaiju prehistoric creatures and
even star wars also smash at
notification bell for regular updates on
new videos so let's get on with Cthulhu
in the monster verse HP Lovecraft
describes Cthulhu as a monster of
vaguely anthropoid outline but with an
octopus like head whose face was a mass
of feelers a scaly rubbery looking body
produced claws on hind and fore feet and
long narrow wings behind Cthulhu has
been described in appearance as
resembling an octopus a dragon and a
human hundreds of metres tall with web
human looking arms and legs and a pair
of rudimentary wings on his back
cooter whose head is depicted as similar
to Godzilla monster versus Scylla
Kizuna was born on the planet Brule
located in the 23rd nebula he traveled
to the stars or where he spawn his
offsprings and along with his children
and the star spawn of Cthulhu he
traveled to Saturn and then to earth
they landed on a continent in the
Pacific Ocean and built the city early
Cthulhu receives resistance from the
elder things who also lived on the
planet long time ago
they reached war for the planet Earth
until a truce was made
Cthulhu then went into a deep
hibernation within
so imagine Cthulhu landing on earth in
the modern age after the reawakening of
the Titans and since he is of alien
origin his welcome would be somehow
mixed in reaction even with the Titans
earth at this time had rid himself off
the tree headed Dragon King King
Ghidorah
during its battle with godzilla mothra
and humans in boston Casula would find
himself in a planet filled with very
powerful monsters that are very
territorial and follow a king he was
none other than Titanus Gojira but
Cthulhu is a very powerful entity being
nearly got like two humans
Kizuna is immortal and has great
strength and can endure great amounts of
damage and can only be killed by a near
omnipotent power using his wings he is
capable of true flight he possesses vast
intelligence and awareness as he knows
all that is occurring in the universe at
once and he has great psychic abilities
as he can communicate telepathically but
impressive has he ears the previous
alien invader of the most diverse planet
Earth also had similar powers it was
gigantic in size had the ability of
flight could command other beings with
its alpha call of course this creature
was most a zero and was disintegrated by
Godzilla during the Battle of Boston in
the king of the monsters timeline but
how would he fare against Earth's Titans
and what he actually come to a truce and
live quietly in a dream state as he
planned to okay so let's say that
Cthulhu Lannon in the Pacific Ocean on
Skull Island and immediately finds
himself facing Kong and the other Titans
who are drawn to the island maybe as a
plot to his it was because he was on
Skull Island that he sounded a call that
attracted the other Titans there since
it was thought that Cthulhu was easily
more than 300 meters tall or a thousand
feet two and a half times the height of
Godzilla who stands at 400 feet tall he
would have easily crushed Kong in battle
in Skull Island and also stood his
ground against the other Titans
but would he stand a chance against
Godzilla his enormous size and strength
might prove an advantage over the g-man
but with the atomic breath
Godzilla could beat him back and then
would end in a standoff being the king
of earth Godzilla would now have allies
in the fight against Cthulhu behemoth
Methuselah Silla Ronan and maybe Mothra
with HEDIS call for assistance and stand
5 on 1 against Cthulhu maybe 6 on one
this scenario would prove disastrous for
the great old one and he would
immediately leave earth for another
planet another scenario is that he lands
in the ocean and goes down to the
deepest depths and fall asleep fall into
a deathlike slumber but then again the
ocean is Godzilla's main territory and
he would immediately go to inspect this
new inhabitant there is a chance that
Godzilla would not even find him as
Cthulhu could be giving no life science
at all when he slumbers his dream
telepathic state could even send science
to the g-man that as a great old one he
was not there for conflict and not even
there to share the same food source but
since his powers include mental
manipulation and non-existent realm
creation he might as well be right in
front of Godzilla and would not be
detectable since he will be in some sort
of a nether plane or dimension but even
then maybe Godzilla finds Cthulhu
awakens him with his first attack and
that would give the g-man the advantage
and go for the kill or Cthulhu being way
bigger in size and in an environment
that would not allow other Titans to
assess Godzilla he might even win with
that it's up to you guys in the comment
section so do like share and subscribe
to our channel for more related content
on monsters and Kai's you also commend
the videos you want us to make and if we
are familiar with the creatures we will
give it a go
you